as we said earlier I've known you a long
time you look I think you look healthy
these days I think you're taking care of
yourself I um I feel like I'm I'm
getting fat a lot no you don't look fat
I couldn't show you no no
[Applause]
uh and I'm always complaining about
getting bigger and bigger and I I have
been uh and I can play I've been
complaining about that for the last like
18 years uh but then I found this on the
uh on the internet I brought it uh so I
feel
obligated it's essential beers it's a
list of essential Bears yes and it's
famous people who are famous uh yeah
Billy Mays yeah yeah uh Bill Murray
that's Kevin James
oh there you are yeah so that everybody
knows where the bear is yeah it's a big
uh you know it's what it's a big hairy
man yeah
uh who uh gay people want to have sex
with yeah
which I'm not opposed to at all right
like not now not the second but I would
you'd be happy to do it but now that I
know that like I'm essential
I don't feel like I can't lose I don't
want to lose the weight
I need you they need me they need you
I'm number 12 on the list next to you
know after like three dead people
and the spokesperson for I don't know
QVC yeah now uh you uh I know you and
you've said that you're
you're happiest when you're annoying
people you like to annoy people I do
I do I uh it's been the way you've
always been you just like to annoy
people yes I mean I started annoying my
father who still hates me yeah uh yeah
uh but I yeah and now I kind of do it
professionally so that's good it worked
out yeah professional annoyer
you can you tell us in an instance where
you went and because you got in some
trouble in public once for annoying
people you went well I got it back
basically it kind of it backfired I it
was a birthday party I I had like a few
years ago
and it was sort of a surprise party and
it took place at the back of a bar
and uh I walked I didn't know everybody
was going to be there so there's about
30 people and
um when I got back there everyone
started to sing Happy Birthday
but they just stopped at the ha part so
they just said hi
and they wouldn't stop
and like literally for like 10 minutes
until we got kicked out you all got
kicked out this is your friend's so that
was so irritated with you yeah they've
got me back and annoyed me but yeah yeah
but it probably didn't even annoy you
you like that kind of weird no and now I
do it when anyone has a birthday I do
that
like if I'm ever at a birthday party I
just go
[Laughter]
my father's 84th you didn't do it you
didn't you didn't know what your father
did hell yeah
that's awful got you again Dad
[Music]
[Applause]